you
hey welcome everybody we are here again
awaiting just moments away from a Donald
Trump and coronavirus task force press
briefing Donald Trump announcing this
morning that he has a big announcement
from the FDA we don't know what it will
be but we do actually have some pretty
important news about one of the clinical
trials that I've been looking at and so
we're going to be looking at that
momentarily we are live on YouTube
twitch and Facebook I've been trying to
carry all of these press briefings live
basically for two reasons number one we
need people to follow the guidelines and
anything I can do to amplify what the
guidelines are which are stay out of
bars and restaurants stay home don't
send kids to school all of this stuff
we're trying to do number two we also
want to stay on top of the latest
developments and any opportunity to do
that is of course very very much welcome
I will take your comments and questions
up until they get started you can send
them if you're watching on YouTube via
super chat you can send them on Twitch
with a twitch subscription messages for
example filthy film just did so and says
hashtag free she'll miss covett miss
Gavin free Shelly Miscavige Scientology
there you go
okay that is that's a message that's a
message and we welcome all messages we
also do have the coupon code running at
join pakman.com 20 20 now with a goal of
25 members here is some act and I've got
the audio up here so as soon as they
start we are going to hear it we've been
following a bunch of different clinical
trials we've been looking at clinical
trials of REM des aveer a began their
starting antibody treatments there's a
lot of different things going on this is
actual good news okay this is serious
Fujifilm back years ago developed a drug
called a vegan whose other name is fav
appear aver i hope i'm pronouncing that
correctly this is one of the clinical
trials that's been going on there has
been a successful clinical trial and it
seems to work
very well okay this this is real stuff
medical authorities in China have set a
drug used in Japan to treat new strains
of influenza appeared to be effective in
coronavirus patients according to
Japanese media Jang's Jin min an
official at China's science and tech
ministry said philippa ver developed by
a subsidiary of Fujifilm had produced
encouraging outcomes in clinical trials
in Wuhan and Shenzhen involving 340
patients this is not now 20 people they
gave it to and it sort of throw
something at the wall and see what
sticks this is serious there has been a
concern about side-effects zhang says it
has a high degree of safety and is
clearly effective in treatment patients
who were given the medicine in Shenzhen
were turnt it turns negative for the
virus after a median of four days after
becoming positive compared with a median
of 11 days for those not treated in
addition and this is important x-rays
confirmed improvements in lung condition
in 91% of patients treated with favilla
vert compared to 62% of those without
the drug that's about 50% more effective
again this drug is also known as a began
and it was was developed in 2014 for
whatever reason Fujifilm is not
currently commenting on the claims share
is surged because this is capitalist
coronavirus as we know drugs and doctors
in Japan are using the same drugs in
clinical studies on coronavirus patients
with mild to moderate symptoms hoping it
will prevent the virus from multiplying
in patients very very important this
next paragraph ok a Japanese Health
Ministry source suggests that the drug
was not as effective in people with more
severe symptoms that's important to know
this is not going to be we cure
everybody regardless of risk if you're
older if you have a more severe case
it's not clear that this works well at
all the point is shorten the amount of
time that mild cases are contagious
that is very important we've given a
began to 70 to 80 people it doesn't seem
to work that well when the virus has
already multiplied the same limitations
had been identified in studies involving
coronavirus patients using a combination
of HIV
antiretrovirals of retrovirals lepen
aver and ritonavir we have also been
covering those a health official told
the man Ichi the drug could be approved
as early as May but if the results of
clinical research are delayed approval
could be delayed this is serious and
this is very very good news and we are
going to be tracking that very closely
and of course May at this point is worth
six weeks from May right so this is very
very important stuff we're waiting for
Donald Trump let me say thanks to Aaron
McCray who is new member number one
today at join pakman.com thanks Aaron
really appreciate your support and
appreciate the support of everybody who
has been watching the streams this is
important stuff that's why we're
covering it we have some super chats
coming in hamiltonian says prediction
for today they still won't take the
necessary steps to slow this down Trump
only cares about the stock market
speaking of the stock market it's sorry
about that let me get back here the
stock market crashing once again as many
of you probably know we are down again
1,300 points you know what's absolutely
insane seeing down 6.2 7% doesn't even
feel that bad when the other day we were
down 12 13 % that it's absolutely crazy
that that's the new reality but alas
that's where we are we are about two
minutes from the start of the of today's
briefing I'm Mikey says disgusting he's
now branding at China virus yeah I have
a long commentary about that on today's
broadcast show which I just filmed so
you'll see that video a little later
Trey Mason says think we'll get power
plants closing because of no workers I
don't think that supermarkets and other
you know utilities and the like I think
they're probably going going to be
staying open even if it puts workers at
risk
Michael 23 says why is Trump doing a
trillion dollar bailout on US isn't that
evil socialism yeah I said yesterday
stuff that we're always told we can't
now we're told we can't afford not to
which is a very very drastic change I
think things have changed very very
quickly welcome to everybody who's
joining me on twitch YouTube and
Facebook we are about two minutes from
one minute from the scheduled White
House coronavirus
briefing Donald Trump tweeting earlier
that he has a big announcement from the
FDA but again very big news out of Japan
and China tests of a began have gone
well a clinical trial of 340 has gone
very well on mild to moderate cases and
we're going to continue following that
for sure as we continue to learn more
about it if you're joining us on YouTube
please do me the favor of hitting the
like button and the subscribe button
thanks to people who do that the streams
have been getting more and more viewers
which is important we want to get these
guidelines out to as many people as
possible and you can also if you are
watching on YouTube send me a super chat
which will show up right there where
doctor funny just showed up let me know
where you are and what measures you are
taking at this point doctor funny says
MD here in the Midwest we still have not
taken this seriously enough no supplies
no ability to test except in patients
that are already sick this is going to
be very bad unless you are a celebrity
or an athlete in which case you can get
tested pretty damn quickly that's what
we found out over the last few days but
average people unless you are quite sick
you are going to have a very difficult
time getting a test and that's part of
why these numbers are as low as they are
when you look at the u.s. which now has
seventy seventy seven hundred seventy
four hundred official cases this number
could be a hundred thousand it could be
five hundred thousand we don't know the
level of asymptomatic young people in
South Korea when they widely tested
suggests a ton of people have no
symptoms and are carrying this and we
don't have tests we're only testing
serious cases I know someone who is told
that her test results could take a
long as two weeks to come back two weeks
can you imagine so we've got a real
problem and the bottom line is we can't
wait for testing to pull out all the
stops that's that's the unfortunate
reality Kowalski from Nebraska says sold
my calves February 14th
price has fallen 25% yeah I think
Kowalski you're what like a cattle
rancher out in Nebraska or something
like that let me say thank you to Aston
vine who has subscribed with twitch
prime I appreciate that
consider grabbing a twitch subscription
if you were watching on twitch and
remember that we do have this coupon
code 20/20 now which is a 66% discount
things have gotten brutal right that's
why we're at 66% off 66% discount off of
a membership at join pakman.com we have
one new member so far that's a sad
number that's a sad number but I trust
that it may go a little higher as we
wait for the Donald Trump coronavirus
task force Donald Trump claiming
claiming that he has a big announcement
from the FDA we will see high Spooky's
says 5.7 magnitude earthquake in Salt
Lake City Utah this morning I didn't
hear about that tag our Ian says I work
in a guitar store people touch
everything I also run our lesson
department so far not shutting down dumb
dumb dumb that's got to get shut down
immediately every dentist I know in
Boston is shutting down
dentists extremely extremely dentists
dental office is extremely at risk dr.
funnie says the number of positives is
likely a factor of 10 raised to the 4 or
5 compared to current positives yes it's
it's extremely high extremely extremely
high and we just don't know the real
number Jonathan says David what are your
thoughts on the impact of the virus on
the upcoming election could Trump use
the crisis as a way to stay in office if
he loses I don't want to do that right
now because I'm actually gonna have a
full video about that on Friday and the
answer is basically no basically no so
I'll have a full commentary for
I want to make sure it's properly
properly researched as well okay
Michael says I work at Disney World and
a guest told me their work is going to
quarantine them because they went to
Disney which is now closed but only the
hotels interesting doctor funny has
grabbed a youtube subscription at the
SOI boy level thanks very much just a
reminder the tracker here is website
memberships at join pakman.com what do
you guys think Trump's big FDA
announcement is going to be as the as
the stock market continues to implode
let's look at Trump's tweet earlier
today a number of tweets mentioning
coronavirus China virus Chinese virus
Trump tweeting about his approval rating
but let's see his tweet here it is I
will be having a news conference today
to discuss very important news from the
FDA considering the Chinese virus and we
just don't know what that news is at
this point in time but we will hopefully
learn very very soon let me say thank
you to Brandon Thompson brandon has just
grabbed a membership at join pakman.com
Thank You Brandon I really appreciate
that support and you can join Brandon at
join pakman.com Daniel ocean says I sell
personal protective equipment been sold
out for weeks no ETA on new stock
importers say their shipments were sent
back to China where most of it is made
incredible incredible juni McGraw says
I'm a bartender in Chicago and all the
restaurants are closed which is good for
not spreading the virus bad for those
that pay rent yes yes semi-truck driver
says I'm a truck driver
not surprising and it's been weird to
say the least the trucking industry is
one of the least respectable industries
and we will be needed ASAP yeah
listen health workers Supermarket
workers people working in shipping
logistics post office I went to the post
office yesterday had to pick up some
stuff and everybody's there everybody's
just there and working and truck drivers
as well continue
to keep the supply chains moving
Christopher Simpson has also grabbed a
youtube membership at the SOI boy level
very much appreciate that and let me say
thank you as well to Philip Paradiso
Philip Paradiso s-- is new member number
three at join pakman.com geo Shepherd is
new member number four at join
pakman.com thank you very much
appreciate that support and remember you
know we're doing these streams
regardless if you are watching on
youtube a really little thing you can do
is make sure to hit like and subscribed
when you do that youtube realizes this
is a great stream to recommend to people
searching for the coronavirus press
conference and then more people come in
currently at thirty thirty two hundred
and climbing very quickly also by the
way welcome to our folks watching on
facebook live we have been doing every
one of these conferences on facebook
live and what was often just fifty or a
hundred people watching on facebook has
regularly become anywhere between four
and eight hundred and we're going to
continue on facebook twitch and youtube
making it all happen John Sebastian
Pinera says just finished hearing
Trudeau's addressed the Canadians
curious how Trump's address will be I
wouldn't be surprised if he calls that
the Chinese virus
I think Trump's hesitating to call it
the Chinese virus during press
conferences although he did defend
calling it that yesterday when when a
reporter asked him about it
but he's not been calling it that at
least proactively
during the press conferences Joe Neely
says US Navy family here operating at
100% no social distancing instructor at
work is eight and a half months I assume
you mean eight and a half months
pregnant
still working everyday in a class of 300
no cleaning supplies at NEX or
barbershop per employees horrible we're
not going to solve it we're just not
going to solve it if that's the case we
do have the Dow Jones Industrial Average
down another 6% it's it's
coming the new normal becoming the new
normal let me say thanks to Jennifer hey
hey Jennifer Jennifer hey that's funny
actually I didn't even mean to do that
new member number five I feel like an
idiot now but that was not on I was not
deliberately making a dad joke new
member number five Jennifer thank you
David parks is new member number six at
join pakman.com and Brian Graham is new
member number seven at join pakman.com
appreciate that Edward oh no I'm sorry P
Penta is a new member on YouTube Edward
lianca says I'm from Italy entire
country is on lockdown sad but it has to
happen it has to happen
I John mu OMA wale has become a SOI boy
on YouTube pine-sol says is this our
opportunity for mail in or email voting
for presidential election it is and it
is unlikely to happen sadly Geoff
Humboldt says the Chinese virus and the
Slovenian first lady
yes that's we should refer to her that
way for as long as Trump calls it the
Chinese virus it's funny because really
the Epis I'm in it's not funny it's
tragic but the epicenter at this point
is really Europe more than China China's
got it under control it's Europe acting
slowly that's spread it further and very
soon if the US doesn't get it together
it's going to be the u.s. responsible
for further spread and contagion as we
stand by for the coronavirus task force
conference oli peace says when socialism
not socialism when Republican suggests
it very well said yeas acai azure says
I'm a teacher in Japan and got a five
thousand dollar paid vacation yes that
is not what is happening in the United
States that is not what is happening in
the United States by any stretch of the
imagination and you know we're looking
at can we get some people a thousand
mock bucks or something like that but
that is not the we are in very very
different places for sure someone
tweeted me yesterday actually
see if I can find this on my Twitter
page by the way I tweeted this earlier
on April 3rd we get March unemployment
numbers if you think the stock markets
been erratic this month just wait until
we find out unemployment is up
drastically but I tweeted yesterday
testing and treatment ideas someone
tweeted fly to Korea the test is free
you get results in six hours
if the case is confirmed you get free
health care round-trip tickets are ultra
cheap right now I'm not kidding
it's insane that that is not insane to
do right that it's completely crazy that
that is not it's a wild thing to do but
it's not completely nuts
very very surreal situation in which we
find ourselves today I don't for people
asking is the thousand dollar emergency
fund happening we don't know we don't
know Griff has grabbed at which Prime
subscription thanks Griff I appreciate
that
appreciate your support very much let me
say thank you to Peter Dickinson Peter
Dickinson has grabbed a membership at
join pakman.com and his new member
number 8 today thanks Peter and Julianne
domingus is new member number 9 at join
pakman.com Thank You Leon very much
appreciate your support our olace says
don't believe for a minute that China
has it under control they lied about
SARS we have no reason to believe they
aren't hiding numbers you know that was
my initial view but w-h-o investigators
are there the investigators not the
right word
authorities officials and they say China
does have it under control so III I was
skeptical of China's numbers early and
we were right to be but China does seem
according to w-h-o to be clearing about
a thousand cases a day this is a typical
day for China 13 new cases and around a
thousand people who recover which has
reduced the number of active cases in
China to one two three four now just
fifth and on a cases per population not
that this means anything because again
these numbers are so off but
China has fallen very very far down the
most active cases currently that we know
of right I mean in Italy Italy is
testing much more than we are so who
knows again probably a hundred thousand
cases here in the u.s. half a million
cases we just don't know we just don't
know
and we are waiting for the press
conference to begin super chats continue
to come in let's see here
make it simple says here comes a
thousand dollars that may well be jhw HG
dole says I think the strong social
democracies in Europe will weather the
crisis better than the u.s. in the long
run good healthcare systems are the key
yeah you know one of the things that
I've been cautious about saying too much
of this just keeping an eye on the press
conference because there there are
reasons this might take a European
countries and everybody's been saying
this is just because it's early there
eventually the death rates will go up
but it doesn't seem to be happening so
if we look at Germany 27 deaths over ten
120 it's a point two percent death rate
now I know this is not the right way to
calculate it these are just very rough
figures you've got to look at it on
resolved cases only 73 people have
recovered I get it but the numbers
aren't climbing okay you look at France
is not doing quite so well 175 over 55
30 they have a 3% death rate but
Switzerland 27 over 30 70 they're at 0.8
percent UK they're at 2.7 percent
Netherlands is at but Netherlands is at
2.8 percent
Austria however it remains very very low
so there are a number of countries
including Norway Belgium Sweden Denmark
almost nobody is dying I hope it doesn't
change I understand that if they had
late surges of new cases the deaths may
simply be delayed because it's it's
tragically about 17 days on average
for the deaths from the time that they
are diagnosed or show symptoms better
said until we
an outcome as it has been callously
called but those numbers continue to be
held very very low and I think that that
is important to look at and remember
guys that there is likely many multiples
of these numbers of cases in a lot of
places and the death rates in a good way
the death rates may be far lower than
what we currently believe at the same
time that means the contagion is
exponentially exponentially high let me
say thank you to Kai Christian Muller
who is new member number 10 today at
join pakman.com Junior Moreno is new
member number 11 today at join
pakman.com if you're just joining us
we're waiting for a coronavirus briefing
that was scheduled to start 15 minutes
ago we don't know what's going on we're
keeping an eye on the stock markets the
Dow continuing to crater down another
half a percentage point or so since the
last time we we looked at it scheduled
for 11:30 and we are indeed standing by
if you're just joining on youtube please
remember to hit like and subscribe it's
been heartwarming to see the folks that
have been coming into these press
briefings clearly people care about this
when you hit like and subscribe it
really helps us in the YouTube algorithm
it's free it costs nothing and I say the
same thing on Twitch make sure to follow
us and if you're catching this stream on
Facebook and you haven't liked our
Facebook page you can do it there you
can do it there as well okay Austin
Jones says should I invest heavily in
the stock market to get in on these
bailouts and low stock prices I can't
give you financial advice because
everybody's financial situation is
different I am continuing to buy because
I believe that eventually there will be
a recovery and that my age I should be
young enough to get the benefit of that
so as the stock market continues to
crater I buy twice a month and I'm
continuing to accumulate of course I'm
reinvesting dividends my idea is if I
get out of this thing alive if that if
that's the case then I will hopefully a
queue
laid more shares that eventually will
recover that that's my view because what
else can I do right I can't I can't
control it I don't pretend to be able to
time the market so I just keep buying
and wait and we'll see what happens
Aaron Washington says I thought maybe
coronavirus might wake people up too how
bad Trump is and how badly we need a
competent leader like Sanders I fear I
was wrong is there any hope I seen on
the only hope is that Biden defeats
Trump because Bernie's out Bernie
announced Bernie lost three more
primaries last night announced that he
is going to be reassessing his campaign
that's political speak for I'm out it's
just a matter of when and how does he do
it
how does he do it in a way that feels
good to everybody involved as good as it
could possibly feel Jayson pronounced
Jason has grabbed a beta level
subscription on YouTube Glenn's swindler
whoops Glenn's swindler says is it true
that some European countries are letting
young people roam to infect each other
to build up immunity is that a bad idea
should we I don't know that you I am NOT
gonna comment about anything I don't
know about I've not heard common
commentary on that from medical experts
so I don't know Jeremy Comfort says will
Trump be impeached when the virus
subsides I don't believe so a BBC now
taekwando says does waste it does
washing the sinuses using neti wash help
don't know not a doctor only listen to
doctors on this okay Charlie says many
people are saying Trump is going to
speak very strongly today that's what I
read and we don't know why he hasn't yet
the stock market just kind of hanging
around down about six and a half percent
and we continue to wait for a donald
trump arjun siccing says i work for a
private security company in the
netherlands I'm worried about the
contradictions between the w-h-o and the
Dutch Health Organization big props to
everyone working hard these days yet
listen what about the contradiction
between no congregating in more than 10
people and millions of people voting in
primaries I mean I just don't know let
me say thank you and welcome to Keith
Hall who is new member number 12 today
at joined
hackman.com Keith thank you yes yes also
thanks to Roberto Oh Neil
I don't know if you go by bado like beta
or orc Roberto Oh Neil is new member
number 13 today at join pakman.com and I
very much appreciate your support folks
just joining us this was scheduled to
start 15 minutes ago we don't know
what's going on we're just we're just
waiting I don't think we got any updates
from Donald Trump here about the press
conference this was three minutes ago
that's interesting three minutes ago
Trump is supposed to be speaking right
now and he's tweeting if it is indeed
him who knows who knows maybe Trump
forgot about the press conference like
some people are suggesting a BBC now
Taekwondo says the virus dies at a
hundred and thirty three degrees
Fahrenheit could inhaled steam help I
don't know about that I don't I'm not
contributing to any possible
disinformation on that also by the way
if you are just joining us we do have
actually big news today the drug a began
has been tested anecdotally and we now
have a three hundred and forty person
clinical trial it appears as though a
began also known as for the para ver
Philippi Rivera I don't know how that
said it does appear to be very effective
against mild and moderate cases so far
leading to visible lung improvements on
x-rays in ninety percent of mild and
moderate cases shortening the disease
this is very good news
this is science and data that we've been
waiting for and that that's good news
and we'll be covering that more tomorrow
and we'll be covering all of these
developments as we have been Daniel
Cerny has grabbed a youtube subscription
so has Richard Bodnar welcome to two
very special soy boys Billiam says I
mean everything was laid out against
Sanders I don't mean to sound sour but
Cullen Jason Aldridge says five dollars
in recognition of your reliable coverage
great content and additional insight
thank you thank you for the support I
appreciate that JH wh says I'm from
Austria
we had the earliest and strongest
lockdown measures we know it'll hit us
but we want to prevent elderly and
already sick people from dying
Tom Oh Wayne says UK response has been
slow NHS is struggling yes marika says
Millennials are despairing over their
parents thinking they're invincible they
only go to local shops but they don't
accept help zero deaths though Yaz's i
as or says Genki ogre invented a vaccine
but he's hiding it now that can't be
true
that can't be true Baron Steuben says
worried about my relatives in Brazil
balsa narrow rivals Trump's incompetence
yeah he does Kate KTB says New York
college student anxious about no time
line upset representatives decided to
down Republicans decided to downplay the
virus many many people don't view it as
serious because of them it's it's that's
one of the biggest tragedies there is
not only a virus spreading there is
viral disinformation spreading as well
and it seems to be afflicting way more
Republicans than Democrats let me say
thank you and welcome to Hector Suarez
Gummy's who is new member number 1414
today at join pakman.com we are standing
by for the donald trump press conference
and it's very weird that it still has
not started we don't know what's going
on a little tiny recovery for the dow
picking up as we do indeed wait Jack
Maxwell says if you have symptoms don't
touch I've approached in we're seeing
some reports on that and that is
something that doctors are looking at
closely Terrell Bradshaw says takes a
pandemic to get the White House daily
press briefings again apparently
apparently Adams W 216 Trump's handling
of outbreak could help him in November I
actually agree with you this this is not
I don't believe Trump has handled it
well but I agree that the handling of it
could actually end up helping
Trump in November you're just joining us
on Facebook welcome we are standing by
for the coronavirus task force you we we
do now have the ability for people to
get facebook direct memberships to the
show cool new feature that we are
participating in if you're joining us on
YouTube please please please remember to
like this stream and to hit the
subscribe button both are free and so
very much appreciated if you're watching
on twitch remember to follow and you can
also grab a twitch Prime subscription
filippov it's has cheered one bit thank
you for that bit Philip of its I
appreciate that
who Leon Dominguez says maybe they are
trying to get the right mix of drugs or
Trump is to up or down yeah you never
know whether it'll be it'll be upper or
downer Trump at these press conferences
this one now 24 minutes past when it was
supposed to start with the Dow
continuing to just recover a tiny bit
but still down more than a brutal 1200
points Trump tweeted just a few minutes
ago eight minutes ago he was supposed to
be in a briefing so it's weird we don't
know what's going on but we are standing
by sir Sonic's has grabbed an alpha
level YouTube subscription aquatic llama
says I tried to get a beta membership
won't let me get it stuck in quarantine
waiting for test results from yesterday
hmm Kowalski from Nebraska says ethanol
uses half of u.s. corn oil is too low to
run no idea what you mean Justin Haddix
says you think a ubi for the quarantine
could happen yeah it does look like it
very well could Paul Rogers says destiny
was destroyed in this debate Erica the K
says Trump must hate you keep up the
good work we have no idea where Trump is
it's very very strange Dan allele Fino
has subscribed at join pakman.com and
his new member number 15 look at
at bar folks we're filling up that blue
bar very strongly and I'm keeping a very
strong look at it myself
with those those memberships that are
coming in latest official numbers at
this point are two hundred and eight
thousand coronavirus cases noticed that
in the last ten minutes that went up by
two thousand cases this is now going
it's going it's going crazy at this
point in time we basically have just a
direct vertical rise in the number of
cases growing on a daily basis let's
look at the actual numbers yesterday of
course we had more new cases than on any
previous day same applied to the prior
two days this february twelfth thing was
because of a lot of clinically confirmed
cases and that through the numbers off
but as far as with uniform numbers then
it's going in the very very much wrong
direction and it doesn't look like we're
going to be peaking anytime soon growth
factor as you can see cases excluding
mainland china rising dramatically again
biggest growth number was yesterday
if we had another two thousand cases in
the last ten minutes I would expect
today to surpass this by even more and
the growth factor outside of mainland
China active cases of course there are
now a hundred and seven thousand known
active cases these numbers are almost
meaningless because so many so many
people are infected and they simply
don't know so those are the numbers we
have stock market continuing to recover
just a little bit we don't know why in
advance of Donald Trump's press
conference let me just take a look at
the latest news ticker just to see if
there's any particular explanation for
why this is happening we did see the
earthquake hitting Utah knocking power
out to thousands last thing we need
right now we are expecting the White
House any moment according to according
to NPR any moment this is supposed to
start we do not know why it hasn't but
we are now a half hour
a half-hour late on this on this press
briefing let me say thank you to Raven
II hockey who has subscribed for three
months with twitch prime thank you very
much okay my no skips says sister said
first vaccine person is a crisis actor
oh give me a break
that's weaponized ignorance karpay
Donnelly says stop calling a stipend ubi
it is co-opting the name yeah it's not
really ubi it seems like these are sort
of emergency payouts no one important
hmm
it says what's your favorite song to
play on drums I don't know I don't have
any one one song lots of jello says can
the federal government or state local
governments implement forced quarantines
if so do you think this could happen
within the next week or so we're dealing
with that on Friday on the show so I
don't I don't want to preempt it that's
a real legal question and I want to make
sure I don't spread any mists or
disinformation so I'm gonna wait to
comment on that on Friday
Denise keup says 5.0 I live in Salt Lake
City we did have a 5.7 this morning and
have had 27 aftershocks
can you imagine bad very bad
Jon Barn Holt has grabbed the YouTube
subscription all EP says first boomers
Gen X and Millennials now we got
quarantines very good pun I like that
Dominic Richardson says bernie is out
thoughts oh did he I did not see that
let's see if we can maybe I mean I
announced already that he was getting
out Bernie Sanders suspends let's see
latest bernie sanders suspends okay yeah
I predicted I predicted 10 days ago that
today would be the day so not not
surprising Joe Biden is the nominee if
you know if you find me under reacting
we've known that this was going to
happen
honestly the day before Super Tuesday I
believed that Bernie essentially had no
path and of course that wasn't
mathematically guaranteed but it that's
it yeah
let's see I'll send a tweet about it too
while we're waiting here whoops Bernice
and actually does he have did he tweet
about it is the question Bernie Sanders
where is what is Bernie Sanders Twitter
account um Bernie Sanders having trouble
finding it here
there it is Bernie Sanders one hour okay
he hasn't he hasn't tweeted about it
Bernie whoops Bernie Sanders is out
suspending campaign right decision sad
no path to nomination it's over what
next
there we go we're just waiting for Trump
to speak we don't we don't know what's
going on so we're just I'm hearing from
you guys and uh there we go okay uh
let's see here what else is going on
Oh super chats continue to come in as we
wait Manuel Rivera says oh I missed it
hi david fellow RG living in germany
here how socialists do you think Trump
will get following you every day folks
stay home I would ask so Papa um I don't
know how socialist Trump will gap I
don't know these are unprecedented times
cosa è Thalgo says Italy and France
numbers haven't been posted yet we know
yeah it's gonna get ugly when they get
posted clever to swear says how much do
you bet the tiny doctor will make the
curve hand gesture while having a sore
throat I like him and it is by far the
smartest guy on stage yeah Anthony foul
she does always seem to have a sore
throat he may just have a raspy voice
but he probably will make that he does
that very often with that curve thing
Superman says do you think Bernie
supporters are saying they won't vote
for Joe just to push the establishment
Joe or progressive policy concessions I
don't know I don't pretend to know what
Bernie er Buster's
are planning to do aaron washington says
the glorious irony carbon footprints are
shrinking because of lock downs and
shutdowns more people need to link
coronavirus with climate change very
true Charlie says David can you clarify
the different options for subscribing
and supporting directly via your website
YouTube super chat other my small brain
is having trouble tracking it what's the
best way to support not on patreon
listen the best way to support is on my
website why because all we pay is 2.9%
to swipe credit cards we keep the rest
every other method twitch YouTube super
chat YouTube subscription Facebook
patreon they all take more than 2.9
percent so the best single way is on on
our website let me say thanks to bro
Sidon who has subscribed with twitch
Prime and says besides politics do you
feel the pandemic will bring out the
evil in humans I hope not I know a lot
of my friends are getting guns and
whatnot
I hope that it does not bring out the
worst in humans and there's an
opportunity for it to bring out the best
optimistically ok sensible talk says
thank you for always being sensible
Jackson says have you and Stephen
Kenneth destiny bunnell ii played chess
yet we played one thirty-second game
I've never played thirty second before
and he won on time would also like to
see you play music together finally go
back on Raj Royale Paul Roger is a beta
member on YouTube tyler solder says only
trump could be later than his Cova drous
Ponce clever to swear says are you sure
Bernie suspended are you absolutely sure
I believe so that's what I saw
let's take a look again Bernie suspends
yeah it uh it does seem that way I'm
seeing a number
reports about it now right or did I get
that wrong can you imagine if he's not
actually suspending now there's a report
that he's just suspending ads oh no
people misread the report that appears
to not be true he's simply suspending
ads we gotta get that [ __ ] deleted right
away holy [ __ ] it appears as though that
has been undone let's clear that and
pretend we never ever tweeted act no I
mean Eliza
but I think it maybe maybe is
prematurely being reported yeah okay I
guess Bernie is simply suspending all
ads and campaigning but not the campaign
what that difference is I don't really
know but it seems the all ads spending
and campaigning is done okay new super
chats coming in Caitlin Campanella
Dietrich nor this side I nor North Side
Irish says Trump is late heard he's
online playing mer entha I don't even
know what that is
Dominic Richardson says now people are
saying he hasn't suspend that I'm
confused
keep it real cam jumps in Matt vams ou
says I'll probably check the Biden box
but who will be motivated enough to
knock doors and do get-out-the-vote he
detests us
Raven Hawk says fYI it's pronounced
Raven hawk oh just spelled weird
thanks for keeping us informed David
Correy courts says what's worse four
years of Trump or eight years of Biden I
think it's another four of Trump shaves
Lee says why doesn't Biden pick Bernie
oh here we go
we have gone live and we are standing by
for the start we see CNN's caitlin
collins delivering a live report as she
often does before these start just
moments before we are keeping an eye on
the dow back down more than 6% and
expecting any moment now that we are
going to hear from Donald Trump and the
whole team the whole team
max Calder says sad I don't really
understand the Bernie hate people have
he's a good guy who pushed the
Democratic Party way more left and
rethink how they raise money agreed 100%
totally agree
jared cam barrows says senator Bernie
Sanders movement has paved the way for
the future of the progressive movement
still a win in my eyes do you agree yeah
listen we learned a lot of the ideas are
popular good ideas Bernie was not a
great candidate had a lot of toxic
people around him the dem socialist
rhetoric wasn't useful the revolution
rhetoric was not useful that's sort of
the bottom line let me say thanks to
Jordan Stacy who is new member number 16
at join pakman.com Thank You Jordan
you can grab a membership at join
pakman.com as well just flip and jam
grabbed a membership on Twitch prime a
smaller crowd today I don't know if you
guys are noticing in the White House
press briefing room interestingly enough
maybe related to social distancing I
don't know Andrew oh hold on a second
Andrew Dwyer says thoughts on Murray
Newman's victory last night very
interesting progressive taking out the
sort of more moderate Democrat we talked
about it last night on stream the dude
says compared to pandemics in previous
centuries do you find it fascinating how
modern society responds I'm weirdly more
encouraged than discouraged here is
Trump and pence a much smaller grief
front claiming a big announcement let's
thank you very much I would like to
begin by announcing some important
developments in our war against the
Chinese virus oh he's doing it Chinese
folk in the defense production act he's
invoking just in case we need it in
other words I think you all know what it
is let's see how the market reacts good
things if we need it and we will we will
have it completed signing it in just a
little while right after I'm finished
with this conference I'll be signing it
it's prepared to go so we will be
invoking the defense production Act last
week I signed an emergency declaration
under the Stafford Act
which is you know we invoked previously
and which activated FEMA's National
Response Coordination Center FEMA now is
fully engaged Deemer at the highest
levels today FEMA is activated in every
region we are at level one level one
being the highest level which we will
work with and we've been working with
him I've done a lot of work with FEMA
they're incredible it's always been on
hurricanes or tornados they're right now
in Tennessee a large group working in
Tennessee have been incredible there was
tragic event Alabama last year also a
tornado and then obviously the numerous
hurricanes and different locations that
were in some cases very devastating and
in every case FEMA came through this is
a very different kind of a work for FEMA
but they will come through as they
always do we have tremendous people
tremendous talent in FEMA we're sending
upon request the two hospital ships
they're being prepared right now they're
introspective ships they're the big
white ships with the Red Cross on the
sides one is called the mercy and the
other is called the Comfort and they are
in tip-top shape they soon will be
they're getting ready to come up to New
York I spoke with Governor Cuomo about
it he's excited about it
syttende I also we haven't made the
final determination as to where it's
going to go in the West Coast the
comfort is located now in San Diego and
it's going to be will be picking the
destination fairly shortly so those two
ships are being prepared to go and they
can be launched over the next week or so
depending on need earlier this week the
first clinical trial of the vaccine
candidate for the virus began in
Washington State as you probably know
the genetic sequence of the virus was
first published in January but thanks to
the unprecedented partnership between
the FDA and
and the private sector we've reached
human trials for the vaccine just eight
weeks later that's a record by many many
months likely a year OS to take years to
do this and and now we did it just in a
very short while that's the fastest
development in history of what we're
doing with regard to the vaccine making
very very big progress today I can
announce further steps to expand testing
capacity we're working with several
groups to determine if the self swab a
much easier process than the current
process that's we need very nice to do I
can tell you because I did it but we
have a current process that's a little
bit difficult if you haven't done the
the groups are working on determining if
a self swab by an individual is as
effective as the other the others very
effective very accurate but we're gonna
see if we can do a self swab which is
swab would be a lot more popular I can
tell you that super popular so and that
would be administered also by a health
official but it would be a lot easier to
do you don't swap by a health official
the fact is that the health
professionals would it would free it
would free up a lot let me just say the
self swab is what it is it's a self so
if you do it yourself oh you do know
there has to be issued by a health
professional and it's something that is
quite difficult and we think it's
working out for the self swab and if it
would test positive the people would go
and they would do what they have to do
but we think that's probably working out
I've asked the FDA to cut through the
red tape and reduce regulatory barriers
we are looking at some very exciting
things and I'm going to be holding the
second news conference either today
we're going to talk about the FDA some
things are happening that are quite
exciting and we're gonna be doing that
either later today or tomorrow fairly
early tomorrow so we'll see what happens
the FTAA my instructions is been working
very very hard on a number of
developments and we'll be discussing
them with you later today or tomorrow
hmm and this afternoon I'll be meeting
with nurses on the front lines of the
battle against the virus they're truly
American heroes they want to get it done
they're incredible people so we're gonna
be meeting with nurses and actually look
forward to that very brave they're
taking a lot of risk and they they have
done an incredible job and they never
complained today I'm also announcing
that the Department of Housing and Urban
Development is providing immediate
relief to renters and homeowners by
suspending all foreclosures and
evictions until the end of April hmm so
we're working very closely what about
payment dr. ben Carson and everybody
from HUD every generation of Americans
has been called to make shared
sacrifices for the good of the nation
in World War two young people in their
teenage years volunteered to fight they
wanted to fight so badly because they
love our country workers refused to go
home and slept in factory floors to keep
assembly lines running and you know the
numbers of ships that they built through
in World War two to this day has never
nothing like that has ever been equal
they were doing ships doing a literally
on a daily basis nobody's ever seen
anything like it
and to this day nobody's seen anything
like that what they were able to do
during World War two and now it's our
time we must sacrifice together because
we are all in this together and we'll
come through together it's the invisible
enemy that's always the toughest enemy
the invisible enemy but we're going to
defeat the invisible enemy I think we're
going to do it even faster than we
thought and it will be a complete
victory it'll be a total victory so
we'll have a second conference again
having to do with the FDA and this I
think it's gonna be potentially a very
exciting news conference excitement and
we will do it as quickly as we can so
whether it's today or tomorrow and all
with
ask mike pence to say a few words and
thank you very much
pencil brown-nose now Thank You mr.
president
the White House coronavirus task force
met this morning and now that we have
cases in all 50 states we're continuing
to move out on the president's call to
bring the full resources of the federal
government a full partnership with every
state and territory the full power of
the American economy to support
businesses and families as the president
says to us and every day we'll do
whatever it takes we're all in this
together
yesterday the president met with the
tourism industry executives and also had
an engaging discussion with all the top
companies in our industrial and medical
supply chain the president as you all
are were also announced today that by
mutual consent the northern border to
Canada will be closed to non-essential
travel this does not include essential
travel or the transit of goods but it
was through a mutual discussion that
took place this morning between the
president and Prime Minister Trudeau and
the Department of Homeland Security will
be effectuating at that decision
president spoke with some of the
nation's top business leaders today
again to speak about the supply chain in
the country and for our part we're going
to be conducting a conference call later
today with state and local health
officials to renew our ongoing
commitment of cooperation and
collaboration as the president said last
week in signing the Stafford act
he stood up the National Response
Coordination Center and today at the
president's direction FEMA has gone to
level 1 FEMA's mission is to support
disasters that are locally executed
state managed and federally supportive
and tomorrow the president will be
hosting all the nation's governor's from
a video conference at FEMA to ensure
that they have full connection to all of
the activated regions for FEMA
going forward and with regard to testing
I'm pleased to report that we're
increasing the number
tests being performed by the thousands
every day thanks to the public-private
partnership that President Trump forged
with commercial laboratories around the
country
trust great experts tell us to remind
every American it's important to
remember people without symptoms should
not get tested we want to make sure that
the supply of testing is there for those
that need it most or are symptomatic or
in the vulnerable population dr. deborah
birx in a moment will address the
progress that we're making on testing
the infection rate our recommendations
to every America as well as some
important new findings about the impact
on youth that we're gaining from data
that's coming in data from Europe
that'll be important to every every
American on the subject of supplies the
president has our task force extremely
focused as the president mentioned
yesterday mentioned that he's invoking
the defense production act today
secretary Esper in a few moments will
describe the ongoing efforts that the
Department of Defense is taking to make
medical resources available Secretary
Robert Wilkie will announce decisions
the VA has made to expand hospital
capacity within their system also with
regard to medical personnel at the
president's Direction HHS is issuing a
regulation today that will allow all
doctors and medical professionals to
practice across state lines to meet the
needs of hospitals that may arise in
adjoining that's actually areas in
addition to that we are again today
asking every American and our medical
community leaders and hospitals to
partner with us in delaying elective
procedures across the country in our
health care system to ensure that
medical supplies and medical capacity go
over they're needed most Seema Verma
will describe guidance that CMS will be
issuing on that front
and finally just I want to remind every
American of the president's 15 day
guidance to slow the spread we are
grateful for members of the media and
the general public that are adhering to
these sharing them with neighbors and
friends all of our experts
continue to believe that if every
American will do their part and embrace
and put into practice these principles
that we can significantly limit the
reach of the corona virus in the weeks
and months ahead thank you very much
thank you
Thank You mr. president mr. vice
president so you know we continue to
look at data every single day there are
concerning reports coming out of France
and Italy about some young people
getting seriously ill and very seriously
ill in the icy use we think part of this
may be that people heated the early data
coming out of China
and coming out of South Korea without
the elderly or those with pre-existing
medical conditions where a particular
risk it may have been that the
millennial generation our largest
generation our future generation that
will carry us through for the next
multiple decades there may be
disproportional a number of infections
among that group and so even if it's a
rare occurrence it may be seen more
frequently in that group yes evident now
so we're looking at that information
very carefully we have not seen any
significant mortality in the children
but we are concerned about the early
reports coming out of Italy and France
so again I'm gonna call on that
generation is there part of that group
that brought us innovation particularly
throughout all of their ability to look
around corners and skip through games
and I always went level by level I
didn't realize that you could go from
level 3 to level 7 oh dear that's what
they've taught us they look for things
that we don't see we need them to be
healthy so again not all in calling on
you to adhere what's in the agai dense
but to really ensure that each and every
one of you are protecting each other and
so we cannot have these large gatherings
that continue to occur throughout the
country for people who are off work to
then be socializing in large groups and
spreading the virus you have the
potential then to spread it to someone
who does have a condition that
none of us knew about and calls them to
have a disastrous good luck telling that
to Emily on the testing piece and what
we're learning more I know you know last
week and bringing the private sector I
think what has been exciting to me over
the last two and a half weeks is to see
this administration harness the full
capacity of the private sector
understanding that a lot of our
solutions that we need to confront this
virus a lot rely on the private sector
bringing the private sector commercial
labs was critical into this process we
are now beginning to see that they have
spread out in a prioritized way because
we asked them to prioritize the regions
that were mostly affected and so you
still may have difficulty getting tests
in areas that do not have significant
cases we've had them prioritized the
regions where we need diagnosis and
their diagnostic percent remember I told
you South Korea was under 4% so 96% of
people were negative the last report
we've seen from the laboratories have
about a 7 plus percent positivity rate
still 93 plus percent or 92% are
negative but I think that's encouraging
to me personally that we're prioritizing
appropriately to those areas that have
the greatest need today and yesterday
thermo Fisher
pushed out most of their laboratory
testing capacity and that will
dramatically increase the at platform
and the ability to run additional tests
in addition to Roche so I appreciate
everybody's attention to these numbers
I'm I'm excited that we've prioritized
where the need was the greatest but
again please follow the guidance and
please make sure in every report that
you're putting out that you're talking
about the presidential guidance to
actually stop the spread of this virus
thank you thank you
so good afternoon everyone and I want to
provide an update on DoD's coronavirus
up efforts as we continue to focus on
our three priorities that's first of all
protecting our personnel and their
families second safeguarding our
national security mission capabilities
and third of course supporting the
administration's whole-of-government
approach first of all though I do want
to assure the American people that the
United States military remains ready and
capable of defending the country and our
interests abroad now with that the
department is leaning forward in our
response to kovat 19 we have issued
international and domestic travel
restrictions to all DoD personnel and
Families that should dramatically reduce
potential exposure to the virus those
have been in place for some time now as
I announced yesterday the Department of
fence will make available up to five
million n95 respirator masks and other
personal protective equipment from our
own strategic reserves to the Department
of Health and Human Services for
distribution the first 1 million masks
will be available immediately we're also
prepared to distribute to HHS up to
2,000 operational deployable ventilators
for use as needed yesterday I was at
Fort Detrick Maryland which is probably
the military's a premier Research
Institute where I got updated on the
incredible work our people are doing as
part of the interagency team to work on
vaccines and therapeutics they are
making great progress there we also have
announced that we've certified our 16th
lab or will soon certified our 16th lab
to help with processing tests from
across the country additionally I have
directed as the president mentioned that
the hospital ships mercy and comfort be
prepared to deploy to increase the
nation's medical capacity and we have
also alerted a variety of filled and
expeditionary hospitals to be prepared
to deploy as well as needed based on
direction from the commander in chief
today a leadership from the Army Corps
of Engineers is in New York meeting with
Governor Cuomo and his team I spoke with
Governor Cuomo yesterday and other
governors I will be speaking to more in
the coming days to make sure that they
know what DoD can provide through our
system to and to address their needs in
my conversations with governor's and
members of Congress about the ADIZ
resources
made it clear that we will continue to
support the administration's
comprehensive efforts and the country
every step of the way while ensuring our
nation's security remains the top
priority I want to conclude by thanking
again all of our service members and
their families who have been affected by
this outbreak they are all great heroes
we are continued to support them
throughout this we are all in this
together thank you all very much thank
you very much so yesterday the president
made a very important announcement about
telehealth and this is allowing our 62
million seniors to be able to get some
medical services from the safety of
their home reducing their risk and
without any co-pays but we're also
making sure that the health care system
is prepared and that those on the front
lines have the support that they need
the reality is the stakes are high and
we need to preserve personal protective
equipment for those that are on the
frontlines of this fight and to that end
we have put out guidelines over the last
two weeks to expand the types of masks
that can be used in routine care and
saving those and 95s for the most risky
situations conserving personal
protective equipment is also essential
to combat the virus
so today CMS will announce detailed
recommendations to further promote this
needed conservation specifically by
limiting non-essential elective medical
and surgical procedures including dental
procedures we believe that these
recommendations will help surgeons
patients and hospitals prioritize what
is essential while leading the ultimate
decision in the hands of state and local
health officials and those clinicians
who have direct responsibility to their
patients and we urge providers and
clinicians and patients to seriously
consider these recommendations they will
not only preserve equipment but it also
allows doctors and nurses to help those
that are on the frontlines and it will
protect patients from unnecessary
exposure to the virus we fully
appreciate that this is going to have a
major impact on the health care system
but the shared sacrifice is essential to
help those that are on the frontlines
and I want to thank the medical
societies such as the American College
of Surgeons and the
American Dental Association that took a
proactive approach and already posted
these recommendations and we've also
talked to the American Medical
Association and they have fully
indicated their support for this
recommendation we now invite the entire
healthcare community to join us in this
effort
thank you Thank You mr. president my
instructions from the president were
very clear I was to do everything
imaginable as aggressively as possible
to protect the nine and a half million
veterans who are part of the Department
of Veterans Affairs
last month we established 19 Emergency
Operations centers across the country we
began to limit the number of visitors
who entered our facilities we began I
think the first we were the first system
to begin triaging across the country and
our 170 hospitals the entrance of anyone
into our facility without being
questioned or tested we expanded those
restrictions to those in our 135
community living centers which which
have about 7800 veterans who are in
acute and acute conditions to make sure
that they were protected we also took
the next step and made sure that we
limited the dental surgeries that we
were provided we've cut back by
one-third the number of routine
appointments we have had and we have
canceled elective surgeries these were
all part the president's directed to be
as aggressive in a public health sense
as we could be and I think we have set
the pace for the entire country I will
say we've often said that we work the
most noble mission in the federal
government our veterans have been in the
toughest spots in the world they have
been put in conditional conditions that
are unimaginable to most Americans and
they have responded they've responded
clearly they have responded with passion
and also the 400,000 members of our
department who are out there on the
frontlines the last thing I will say is
that you have heard a lot of
about the fourth mission that VA has our
first three missions are health care
benefits and memorial affairs our fourth
mission is to support the federal
government in times of natural disasters
and pandemics we are the the buttress
force in case that FEMA or HHS calls
upon us to deploy medical professionals
across the country to meet crises we
plan for that every day we are gaming
out emergency preparedness scenarios and
we we stand ready when the president
needs us to expand our mission thank you
was on Capitol Hill talking about the
potential for what could come and he
said that unemployment could skyrocket
to 20 percent are we looking that that
could rival the Great Depression are we
looking at potentially no no I don't
agree that's a absolute total worst-case
scenario but no we don't look at that at
all we're nowhere near it okay why do
you keep calling this the Chinese virus
reports of dozens of
incidents of bias against Chinese
Americans in this country your own a
secretary a czar and says he does not
use this term because ethnicity does not
cause the virus why do you keep using
this comes enjoy this it's not racist at
all no let it okay it comes from China
China comes from China I want to be
accurate
yeah please John are you I have my great
I have great love for all of the people
I would love to hear the people behind
him comment actual as you know China
tried to say at one point maybe this
stuff now that it was caused by American
soldiers that can't happen it's not
gonna happen not as long as I'm
president
it comes from China John Cleese to
questions like good mr. president first
of all an offense procurement act you're
invoking it today senator Sharia said on
the floor a short time ago that it
urgently needs to be put into action to
produce medical supplies particularly
ventilators do you have seen two targets
that you would like to see immediately
spool up and we do have we have
tremendous numbers of ventilators but
there's never been an instance like this
where no matter what you have it's not
enough that would be the case and we
will be it's it's being signed it's
essentially drawn and we're going to
sign it in just a little while if we
need to use it we'll be using it at full
speed ahead
both Peters urgently need to be
do you have some time wasn't to know
whether or not urgent but we will yeah
we do have targets we have targets for
certain pieces of equipment we have
targets for masks you know the masks and
numbers of Basques are incredible we've
ordered millions of them but we need
millions for this a thing like this has
never been requested and it's never
we've never had even think in terms of
these numbers but we need millions of
masks and all of that will be order we
need respirators we need ventilators is
a big thing because it's a complex piece
of equipment so we have a lot of metal
edges but we're going to be ordering
more questions what size will the checks
be that will be sent out to to be
determined we're working with the Senate
right now we're working with everybody
on Capitol Hill there's been tremendous
there really has been I mean with with
some exceptions obviously because it's
always the way it is but there has been
they've been getting along very well
Republicans and Democrats it's a nice
thing very bipartisan so four thousand
dollars what we're gonna see I don't
want to get into that right now John we
we are looking at different numbers
we're looking at timing that would be
different splitting the time splitting
the payments we're looking at a lot of
different things hasn't been determined
yet but it will shortly be determined
and people want to go big as opposed
everybody seems to want to go big and
they want to get to the recovery the big
day is the big thing we can do is get
rid of this horrible I call it the
unseen the unseen enemy you call it you
is it that was in different terms for it
but what it snuck up on us about a
thousand all its it did a hundred and
twenty eight countries I think it's in
something like that very close to that
think of that so it spreads violently
it's a very contagious very very
contagious virus America to be on a
wartime footing
fighting this virus I do I actually do
I'm looking at it that way because you
know if if it got out of control the big
thing we did was a very early stoppage
of people coming in who could be a very
very heavily in 50 question that was a
it was a very good move and it was very
early very very early when most people
including a lot of professionals they
didn't want us to do it that really
saved a lot of lives and yeah I look at
it I view it as a in a sense of wartime
president I mean that's what we're
fighting I mean it's it's a it's a very
tough situation you're you have to do
things you have to you have to close
parts of an economy that six weeks ago
were the best they've ever been made the
best economy we've ever had and then one
day you have to close it down in order
to defeat this enemy and but we're doing
it and we're doing it well and I'll tell
you the American people have been
incredible for the most part they've
been really incredible yeah please you
just said there are a tremendous number
of ventilators that we have but for
weeks
hospitals have been worrying about a
critical shortage that they say we are
not prepared for so why did it take so
long well you know hospitals are
supposed to have ventilators too and
when we have thousands of ventilators it
sounds like a lot but this is a very
unforeseen thing nobody ever thought of
these numbers nobody ever saw numbers
like this except pandemic exerted just
exactly we wouldn't be doing testing and
they decided to do it very very hard to
ramp up now we're getting highly
sophisticated tests and it's going very
well but nobody's ever heard of testing
in the kind of quantities that you're
talking about but
so why did it well we knew it depends it
depends on how it goes
worst case absolutely the best case not
not at all so we're gonna have to see
where it goes but we are ordering
thousands and thousands of ventilators
and they're complex you know these are
complex machines and but we're ordering
them does anybody have a mic from a B
you do how many do we have we have a
specific number of ventilators into
stock pilots in excess of of 10,000 and
you just heard the announcement from the
Department of Defense they'll be adding
several more thousand to that but
president even this morning and
yesterday afternoon speaking with the
the largest companies in the supply
chain in this country we're hearing a
tremendous spirit among industry leaders
here it's about ventilator add to that
volume the stockpiles don't count all of
the ventilators that exist today in the
marketplace and in healthcare facilities
around the country but the president's
given us a a directly to make sure that
our stockpile but just as importantly
working with industry leaders that were
securing the increase in ventilators the
increase in masks gloves our protective
care garments that are all necessary to
lean forward and we're confident we'll
be able to accomplish that with the
incredible cooperation of the supply
chain that drives us in America today
we can give you that assessment but
we'll give it to you but we're ordering
we're ordering a lot more yeah go ahead
in the back
yeah one second one second Kaitlyn we'll
do it in a second what was the tipping
point Friday we talked about it that
Monday you said no one who were not
considering no I said not yet I spoke
with the Prime Minister Trudeau very
good relationship obviously between us
and our two countries and no tipping
point it's just that we want to we want
to isolate from the standpoint we don't
want people coming into contact because
that's the way we're going to win this
war that is so important and we both
thought it was sudden now it's not
affecting trade it's non-essential it's
non-essential crossings
it won't affect trade at all and it was
just something we thought would be good
for both countries yes how can you be
sure the trade and everything that's
being shipped from one side well they're
doing it in a very careful manner you
can only be vigilant and very
professional right but we're not it's
not pertaining at this moment to trade
between the two countries yeah please
yeah about the trillion dollar economic
stimulus package could look something
like fifty billion for the airlines 150
billion dollars in oil using critical
sectors of the economy a 250 billion
dollar payment on April 6th directly to
individuals another 250 billion
on May 18 again directly to individuals
and as well three hundred billion
dollars for small business loan
guarantees is that in the general sense
what could be it could be and we're also
playing with a lot of numbers a lot of
very big numbers and a lot of very small
numbers frankly we will take care we
have to help everybody it was nobody's
fault this happened I mean some people
could say it was somebody's fault
actually but it was nobody's fault and
certainly none of these companies that
all of a sudden had no passengers and
planes and had no passengers on cruise
ships and all of the things that have
happened but I will say that they can't
be blamed for this and we want to keep
those companies vibrant because it's
there's gonna be a comeback very very
quickly as soon as this is solved and it
will be solved we will win and there
will be a comeback and it'll take place
very quickly there's give or take 330
million Americans or so you just do the
math on that that's about $750 a person
a family of four that would be about
three thousand dollars on average again
rough math which is that no I don't want
to say that because it's a moving these
are all old every number that you
mentioned
yes we've talked about those numbers
we're also moving those numbers in both
directions so we'll let you know it'll
be it's it's moving along fast again
there's a great bipartisan effort going
on that that I haven't really seen
before to this extent look it's down the
line and they're looking at it very
seriously and I think would be a great
thing because the others to use a nice
word it's very inconvenient it's very
tough Frasor you tweeted this morning
about your approval rating amongst
Republicans you have said that you give
yourself a ten in terms of handling this
crisis how do you reassure Americans
don't trust you to handwrite prices well
I think we're doing a really good job
you started off with a termination of
the border the people coming in from
China where this is no event I took it
very seriously and when I use the word
calm calm doesn't mean that I'm not
taking it seriously calm means and we
should be calm we should be extremely
calm but yeah ninety five percent within
the Republican Party and over fifty
percent and I also have we have very
great approval numbers I mean people
like the job that we're doing and when
you can't compare this to other
epidemics or if you want to use a
different term you can but within this
country and you look at what's happened
over the years this is being handled
very very professionally where the
greatest professionals in the world
we're doing a good job
nobody has ever been swamped like this
and nothing's been so contagious the
level of contagion has been incredible
actually nobody's seen anything quite
like this yeah Peter go ahead shipped
millions of tests as you and your
colleagues have said why is the federal
government's s of only fifteen fifty
nine thousand tests been processed to
this point we just heard from the
Atlanta public health director saying
that they have fewer than 50 test kits
for more than nine hundred thousand
citizens where Lois Mike so that's a
very critical question and thank you for
asking it so the test kits that we put
out last week through the approval the
rapid movement of that meeting that
President Trump called less than two
weeks ago that has resulted in bringing
our private sector to the table because
the tests and the platform that was out
there could only run between four and
twelve tests per platform per day right
we've now moved into platforms that can
run basically tens of thousands of tests
per day so yeah the reason I'm grateful
for your question because it allows me
to point out that a course then there
was backlog there were individuals who
had been tested
who hadn't have their specimen run
because of the slow throughput it's now
in a high-speed platform so we will see
the number of people diagnosed
dramatically increase over the next four
to five days yes I know some of you will
use that to raise an alarm that we are
worse than Italy because of our slope of
our curve to every American out there it
will be five to six days worth of tests
being run in 24 to 48 hours
so our curves will not be stable until
sometime next week
yikes the reason I talked about thermo
Fisher yesterday is because their
platform is in 2000 Laboratories they're
the ones that are putting out the
million tests this week that will solve
the issue that atlanta and others have
brought up I wanted to be clear we
prioritize the areas we do
county-by-county analyses based on those
analyses on what counties had more than
50 cases we prioritize the test kits we
put out the 400,000 and that's why we're
seeing a seven percent plus positivity
rate we'll be able to expand that
platform and reprioritize based on the
accessibility of the other kids oh boy I
can follow up Howard non-systematic
professional athletes getting tests
while others are waiting in line yes and
can't get them to the web and that did
go to the front of the line well that
you'd have to ask them that question I
mean they I've read no I wouldn't say so
but mascius have been the story of life
that does happen on occasion and on
occasions where some people have been
tested fairly quickly sometimes excuse
me excuse me not inherited a very
obsolete system this was a system that
was out of date obsolete or it was a
system that was never meant to take care
of the kind of quantity the number of
people that we're talking about millions
and millions of people if you go back in
years past like even recently with the
flu nobody had tests before they didn't
test the entire nation
to see whether or not they had flu they
got the flu they got better hopefully
they got better that was it now all of a
sudden they do this very complex testing
what we've done is we've broken it down
we've broken up the system but it was
obsolete and or you could say it was
also a system that just wasn't meant to
handle the kind of volley the volume
that you're talking about we've rebuilt
it into a system that for the future
will be a very good system if you want
to go this route but this was never done
before and I would imagine it will be
done in the future but we built it into
a very good system by using private
companies the great private companies
and I have to say Roush's been doing a
very good job by the way guys remember
the question was how our athletes and
rich people getting tested so quickly
without symptoms that he's talking about
Roche thing like this or even near this
is calling on you to suspend tariffs
with other countries as part of the
response to the corona virus who heads
that group those countries do go check
it's an american free trade i know i'm
sure if free trade look china's paying
those billions and billions of dollars
in tariffs and there's no American
company they haven't even spoken to me
about that China hasn't asked me to do
that but we're getting billions of
dollars here from tariffs from China get
it from a Mara and I can't imagine
Americans asking for that but it could
be maritime for a suspension or
something they'll see what happens
China's having a very rough time they
have their worst year in 76 years as I
understand it they haven't a very very
tough time and then on top of it this
happened with the virus but no we're
taking in billions of dollars a year in
tariffs and this was caused by something
totally unrelated to tariffs asylum
seekers and people who crossed the
southern border illegally
are you planning to invoke 42 USC 265
which would allow you to prohibit entry
of certain people
yes a versa probably today well I think
essential is medical we have military
welcome again medical we have industry
working together and again it's not
affecting trade so things like that but
just leisurely let's go to a restaurant
that have dinner which a lot of people
do they come both ways they go in both
directions that kind of thing we we have
ended on a temporary basis yeah please
go ahead
not close no we're not gotta close it
but we are invoking a that thing setting
a vision that will allow us great
latitude as you know we do the 42
something something yeah go ahead
you know what good because just a week
ago
um you all were standing here telling us
that unless you had sustained contact
with somebody who is symptomatic for
cope in nineteen you really didn't think
to work util the president the vice
president that if they shook hands with
somebody who had this they took a
photograph with with somebody who had
this you didn't really need to worry and
yet several days later we're in a
situation where people are being told
don't leave your houses there are curfew
saying you cannot walk alone at night
after a certain time can you walk us
through what seemed like a very dramatic
we go there yes nasty nasty woman so two
things um we look at data all the time
and I know you're looking at the China
and South Korea data and when you look
at China and South Korea data and you
look what China and South Korea did you
can see that their curves are not only
blunted outside of Wuhan so the Chinese
areas outside of Wuhan blunted curve and
South Korea blunted curve if you look at
their curve today they're already on the
far end of their epidemic curve of
course none of those countries are fully
back to work and so that's what we
worried about to secondly there was a
series of scientific articles published
and I know you've seen them too about
surface contamination I think none of us
really understood the
of surface peace so we're still working
out how much is it by human human
transmission and how much is it by
surface this is why those fundamental
guidelines were put out that says don't
expose yourself to surfaces outside the
home basically what those guidelines are
is don't expose yourself to excess
number of persons who could be
asymptomatic and infected and then the
person-to-person contact and don't
expose yourself to surfaces that could
have had the virus on it for which on
hard surfaces I know we had the
cardboard issue about shipping hard
surfaces not shown in fabric as much or
in cardboard but hard surfaces
transmission these are issues that we
haven't had to deal with before with the
level of respiratory infections and
that's why we have this concern and
that's why the president put out the
guidelines and so it's to cover both of
those pieces that's all new science all
new models I think many of you have the
Imperial study available and looked at
the impact of those that's the first
time those have been modeled as a
comprehensive approach to mitigating an
epidemic
expand the use of investigation
scientists this could put patients at
risk I haven't seen you know I haven't
seen the article we will we are making a
lot of progress therapeutically I will
say that and but I have not seen that
article now we've shut down
non-essential travel to Canada
are you considering shutting down I'll
travel to brunt the spread of the virus
and we've heard from industries like the
airline's who are seeking relief
what other industries or what how
exactly is your administration I'm going
to determine which industries and
businesses well there were certain
industries that people know it with the
airlines would be number one if you look
at what's going on they go from having
the best year they've ever had to having
no passengers because of what we've had
to do in order to win this war it's a
war and so you know basically you know
what many of the industries are what we
want to do is we want to make sure they
all stay together so that after the war
is won we can immediately go right back
up to where we were and even beyond I
think we're gonna go beyond where we
were a lot of people are saying that by
the way we're poised to do that but we
have to win the war first yeah please go
ahead fifty billion dollars today for
those industries but their proposal
doesn't detail which industries we get
that money and how much so aside from
the airlines which you just mentioned
what about the cruise industry the hotel
how much of that money do you see them
we're talking about all of it haven't
detailed it yet we have detailed it to
senators and all of the above members of
the House we have been talking about it
and we're coming up with numbers haven't
gotten there yet but certainly hotel
industry the cruise ship industry the
airline Tso's are all prime candidates
episode
Porter sir when you say which boy then
northern reporter when you say temporary
which is what you said in your tweet did
that mean 30 days I would say 30 days
and hopefully at the end of 30 days
we'll be in great shape
perhaps not taking some of these
warnings as seriously as you'd like some
of those people also seem to be your
supporters and conservatives who may be
quoting some of what you said at the
beginning of this comparing it to the
flu what is your message to them to
really follow what you've been saying so
far and are you concerned that they're
still listening maybe to some of your
earlier comments rather than your more
recent ones well I think my earlier
comments to become I mean I do want
people to become because with nothing
it'll do a lot of time and I wanted to
go quickly so based on the fact that I
wanted to go quickly I hope they just
listened to what we've been saying over
the last period of time we don't want
them gathering and I see they do gather
including on beaches and including in
restaurants young people they don't
realize they're feeling invincible I
don't know if you felt invincible when
you were very young but they were
feeling totally invincible or are
feeling that way but they don't realize
that they can be carrying lots of bad
things home to grandmother and
grandfather and even their parents so we
want them to heed the advice we mean the
advice and I think it's getting through
I do believe it's getting through Jim
sorry is it what I think there a lot of
them watching a lot of these people that
only some people well I think the advice
he'd the advice I just said yeah thank
you thank you Peter you've been very
clear about who you think it's a blame
or where the origins of languages
viruses
nothing no no I don't think I know who
where it came from I don't know if you'd
say Chinese to blame certainly we didn't
get an early run on it it would have
been helpful if we knew about it earlier
you ignored but it comes from China and
it's not a question about that nobody's
questioning that saying that they should
be punished in so many words for
inflicting this on the American people
do you feel that way about well I have a
lot of respect for Tom cotton and I know
exactly what he's been saying and there
were those people that say that so we'll
see what happens thank you a long time
please you had your hand up so nicely
for a long time it's your time thank you
sir we've seen the Chinese government
kick out reporters from The Wall Street
Journal the New York Times The
Washington Post what is your message to
the Chinese when it comes to
transparency and a moment we still have
reporters asking you questions here at
the White House yeah I'm not happy to
see it I don't you know I have my own
disputes with all three of those media
groups I think you know that very well
but I don't like seeing that at all I'm
not happy about that at all yes please
you agree with it do you believe that
China isn't
seeing this upon our country no I don't
believe they're inflicting I think they
could have given us a lot earlier notice
absolutely nation I'm asking because I
see that they're very high you know if
you look I'm ninety five percent in the
Republican Party we just had a poll that
was done by a very reputable group where
I'm beating sleepy Joe Biden by a lot
sleeping in Florida at the state of
Florida and in other states you know so
I don't really know who you're talking
about
hi Jennifer go ahead skipping yeah
explain to them what's coming and they
explained to me where they're coming
from I mean they went from as I said
full planes packed the best year they've
ever had by far water refill boom
one day empty because of what we have to
do to get rid of to win this war or we
would have